[Music]
all right it has now been 270 days since
joe biden abandoned our fellow americans
behind enemy lines in afghanistan and
surrendered to the taliban that doesn't
include thousands of green card holders
that doesn't include of course our
afghan allies many of whom have been
murdered and the taliban is now in full
control returning there right to their
hard line oppressive rule as we
predicted sadly oppressing women young
girls appears morgan grilled a taliban
spokesperson on his new show piers
morgan uncensored about these major
human rights violations take a look at
this a girl should be entitled to go to
school in afghanistan the same way a boy
goes to you yourself said in august last
year that they had nothing to worry
about nothing to be scared about the
issue of secondary
schools education for girls
they are
under consideration let me turn if i may
to the issue of the now compulsory
instruction for all women in afghanistan
to wear a full burka if they go outside
uh 99 percent of the afghan women they
are observing hijab voluntarily his
brand new show by the way piers morgan
uncensored as if there's any other peers
airs uh new episodes four times a week
at foxnation.com
all right so watch very closely this
interview with this taliban guy
um i predicted exactly everything that
would happen it was the worst debacle
withdrawal ever
um even anthony blinken says 126 he
acknowledges americans are trapped
behind enemy lines
many of my congressional sources tell me
that number is much higher then we have
thousands of people that have american
green cards eligible to be in this great
country they were trapped behind enemy
lines and our afghan allies that we
promised we never abandoned they're now
being taken out in the streets and
killed or taken and never to be seen
again never mind the billions of
military equipment so the old taliban is
the new taliban peers this is exactly
what anybody with a brain knew would
happen
exactly right sean and it's a complete
betrayal of americans that were there
and remained there in great danger a
betrayal of all the interpreters and
other afghans who helped uh the the west
in their efforts in afghanistan but most
of all a terrible betrayal of the
afghani women and in this interview i
did with the taliban official spokesman
suhail shaheen was so disingenuous he
just basically told me a bunch of
bare-faced lies you know and i
eventually asked him one simple question
he has two daughters i said do they go
to school he's in doha yes he said they
do and of course they're right there is
the hypocrisy which is riddle through
the taliban ethos one rule for them and
their children another rule for these
poor school girls in afghanistan just to
be completely clear now any girl after
the age of about 12 13 uh is not going
to school and he may say well they're
entitled to they're not allowed to
they're not going to school they are
having their education stolen from them
after two decades of getting used to
having one and then you have this new
draconian rule that afghan women can't
go out in fact they're told to stay at
home and if they do go out they can only
reveal their eyes if there's any breach
of that rule then the male relatives or
their male employer who may be held
responsible they are the enforcers and
if they don't enforce it then they
themselves face imprisonment so you're
you're taking really a step back to the
dark medieval ages with this to the very
worst of taliban 1.0 there is no taliban
2.0 they are just as bad as they were
before and the abandonment of these
people i think is going to be on joe
biden's conscience now for the rest of
his life because it was a catastrophic
failure of foreign policy to just up and
leave and basically hand the country
back to the taliban wolves no i'm glad
you confronted him i thought you did a
really good job with that
what i don't understand is where where
are women's rights groups where are the
where's the gay and lesbian community
because
if you're gay or lesbian they will
murder you we're a human rights activist
in all this because they should be
agreeing we don't agree on everything
but we agree on this we agree that
rights are god-given natural rights from
god not from government and these
fundamental rights do not exist for
these groups in afghanistan and and yet
you don't hear a peep out of most people
peers nothing
nothing and you know we hear a lot from
big corporations like disney when they
want a virtue signal down in florida
about sex education to young kids but
not a word from them about the
oppression of millions of afghani women
in afghanistan because of course it was
a democrat president that created this
fiasco and that shows a political bias
for all these corporations none of them
dare speak out about this kind of thing
let me switch gears to the issue of
doxing and the protesting i call it
intimidation and harassment of supreme
supreme court justices i would imagine
that we might be on other sides as it
relates to the issue of abortion that's
not what this is about it's a big lie
that if roe v wade is overturned that
abortion will be illegal in the u.s it
will not be states will decide what
restrictions or what lack of
restrictions they want liberal states
well i'm sure allow abortion in some
cases they do now up until the moment of
birth which to me is infanticide
but the issue you call these people that
are doxing these justices and protesting
in front of their homes you go as far as
you call them domestic terrorists
explain
i think it is a form of terrorism you
know i think when you mass protest
outside the home of supreme court
justices many of whom have children
young children in some cases and you are
intimidating them that is a form of
terrorism and i'm all for peaceful
protest sean i think it's the
fundamental bedrock of any democracy but
to go and find the homes of supreme
court justices who already i think have
extremely difficult jobs often very
dangerous jobs they're dealing with huge
constitutional issues where there are
people who feel very emotive about it
very angry about it we know there are
lots of crazy people out there do we
really want to encourage them to go down
to a supreme court justice's home and
terrorize them and their families i
think it's unconscionable that this is
happening it shouldn't be allowed to
happen and i think i would say the same
if it was the other way around
politically if these were right-wing
protesters doing it to you know
left-wing judges i'd say the same thing
i just think why are you feeling
immediately reactionary they are trying
to intimidate people into making a
decision which should be completely left
to these judges
could you imagine for a second if i did
anything similar which i would never do
it's too dangerous uh but imagine what
the reaction would be or if donald trump
did it imagine what the reaction will be
again it would be outrage outrage
rightly so rightly so uh piers morgan
yeah thank you don't forget piers show
uncensored on foxnation.com hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else